>>> IT ALL STARTED WITH A BOX ON
MY DOORSTEP.
>> AND A NOTE WITH A QUESTION.
>> I JUST GOT THIS FEELING THAT
IT WASN'T THE KIND OF QUESTION
YOU COULD SAY NO TO.
>> WILL YOU --
>> BE MY --
>> BRIDESMAID.
>> FROM THE PEOPLE WHO BROUGHT
YOU KEEP SWEET, WILD WILD
COUNTRY, AND THE DOCUMENTARY
COMES A NEW STORY, I WAS A
BRIDESMAID.
>> EACH YEAR, MORE THAN 6
MILLION WOMEN FALL INTO THIS
TYPE OF CULT.
THEY PREY ON COLLEGE ROOMMATES
AND SISTERS IN LAW.
>> THEY SELL YOU ON A ONE DAY.
THE BUT FOR 18 MONTHS, I WAS
FULLY SUCKED IN.
>> THERE WAS AN EMAIL CHAIN,
GROUP TEXTS, DM, A WHOLE
CONVERSATION AND VENMO.
>> GOT PULLED INTO A 200
QUESTION POLL ABOUT CUSTOMIZED
SHIRTS.
WE ENDED UP GOING WITH BRIDE
TRIBE.
>> THEY ALSO TARGET ANOTHER
VULNERABLE GROUP, OUTGOING GAY
MEN.
>> I HAVE BEEN A BRIDESMAID AT
NINE WEDDINGS THIS YEAR.
WHENEVER A GIRL STARTS CALLING
ME SIS, I KNOW I'M IN TROUBLE.
>> THE BACHELORETTE PARTY IS THE
FIRST MAJOR RITUAL, ALMOST
ALWAYS IN NASHVILLE.
>> I TRY TODAY SAY I COULDN'T GO
BECAUSE OF MY STUDENT LOANS.
THE MAID OF HONOR TEXTED BACK,
NO WORRIES WITH A SPARKLE EMOJI.
I KNEW WHAT THAT MEANT.
>> AT FIRST, I THOUGHT IT WAS
THE BRIDE IN CHARGE, BUT IT WAS
THE WOMAN UNDER HER, MICHELLE.
>> MICHELLE WAS A SOCIOPATH.
>> FIRST, WE'RE GOING TO BE
GETTING UP AT 6:00 A.M. FOR A
POLL DANCE FITNESS CLASS.
WE'RE GOING TO BE RUNNING A NINE
BIKE PERSON, AND DRINKING,
DRINKING, DRINKING.
>> I'M NOT FEELING SO GOOD, SO
I'M GOING TO MEET YOU GUYS
LATER.
>> OH, THAT'S OKAY.
HEY, BRITTANY, CAN WE TALK FOR A
SEC?
>> I DON'T HAVE MANY MEMORIES
FROM THE BACHELORETTE TRIP
BECAUSE I WAS DRUGGED BY MYSELF.
I HAD NO CHOICE.
THESE WOMEN WERE TERRORIZING
EVERY GAY BAR IN TOWN.
>> AS WITH ALL CULTS, THERE IS A
FINANCIAL ELEMENT.
>> I SPENT $300 ON A BRIDESMAID
DRESS.
THE BRIDES I'VE TRIED OTHER
TIMES TO WEAR IT.
WHERE AM I GOING THAT CALLS FOR
A BLUE CHIFFON GOWN?
>> MORE MONEY, MORE GIFTS, THERE
WAS ALL THIS PENIS STUFF,
SASHES, STRAWS, EVERYONE ACTED
LIKE IT WAS HILARIOUS.
I DIDN'T UNDERSTAND.
>> THE PENIS STUFF IS VERY
FUNNY.
I WILL SAY THAT.
>> AND FINALLY, IT WAS TIME FOR
THE BIG DAY.
>> I WAS SEPARATED FROM MY
BOYFRIEND AND GIVEN A NEW
PARTNER, THE GROOM'S COUSIN
DONNY, WHO WAS INEXPLICABLY 61.
>> FINAL RITUAL WAS THE MOST
DEMEANING.
WE HAD TO WRITE AND PERFORM
ORIGINAL LYRICS TO FRESH PRINCE
OF BELAIR.
>> AND THEN, ALL OF A SUDDEN, IT
WAS OVER.
BUT I JUST GOT ENGAGED.
DON'T WORRY.
I'M GOING TO BE SUCH A CHILL
BRIDE.